hey friends how's it going welcome back
to the deep dive podcast we are kicking
off season two it's very exciting we've
revamped our studio a little bit so if
you watched season one of the podcast
and listen to it you would have seen
kind of the evolution of the studio over
time anyway without further ado uh let
me introduce this podcast episode which
is with dr julie smith who has written
this fantastic book why has nobody told
me this before
julie is a clinical psychologist who has
over three million followers on tik tok
and various other social media platforms
and she shares tips about maximizing our
mental health and understanding our
minds and our brains and how psychology
works and that cool stuff like that that
helps us live healthier happier more
productive lives and in the conversation
we talk a little bit about her success
as a creator how does she go from this
kind of having a very normal health care
type job of being a clinical
psychologist to then randomly deciding
you know what let me stop posting videos
on tik tok we talked about kind of the
feelings behind there the cringe
response and like how she got over the
fear and how
through that decision that she made
about two years ago now she has managed
to inspire millions of people and
educate people about their mental health
in a really cool way and we also talk
about some of the concepts that she
talks about in the book like things like
motivation and fear and grief and
self-doubt and all these other
psychological issues that plague us on a
daily basis and then towards the end of
the podcast we also talk about the idea
of living a meaningful life and that's
topic that i've been thinking a lot
about and i know julie's thought about
it a lot and we talk about some of the
psychological research that's gone into
this idea of living a meaningful life so
yeah hopefully you'll enjoy the
conversation as much as i did uh let's
go for it all right so julie welcome to
the podcast how are you doing thanks for
having me i'm really excited to be here
actually yeah it should be interesting
you're you're a clinical psychologist
yeah what what is a clinical
psychologist like what do you what do
you do sure so a clinical psychologist
works in
well we can work in sort of brain injury
and things like that but i worked in
mental health so i was providing
assessments and psychological therapies
to
you know in all different kinds of
services so i worked in a service that
was purely for ministry of defense for a
while and doing sort of trauma work and
things with veterans
i worked in inpatient and
intensive care awards or in crisis teams
in the community so lots of different
sort of mental health services
offering um you know either very intense
support or longer psychological
therapies okay and so what what sort of
problems were you seeing on a daily
basis in the nhs um
the sort of more severe and enduring end
of of those problems uh you know all
sorts of mental health problems but once
i worked in i started a small private
practice it was just um by myself and
that was more um uh people who were sort
of functioning on a day-to-day basis
working um you know all that sort of
thing and but but struggling with maybe
you know grief or uh burnout or you know
all those sorts of things that that
happen uh more day-to-day okay um so
what's the difference between that and
like what a therapist does
or is it the same thing so it's a
difference in in training so somebody
might become a therapist after being uh
maybe a mental health nurse and then
they might train in certain therapies
for example or do a counseling course
whereas with clinical psychology you
start off doing a psychology degree
and then you work in mental health for a
few years and get your experience do
some research that kind of thing and
then you train and you do your doctorate
so then it's purely in you know
psychological therapies and assessment
and those sorts of things so it's a
training difference really so you have
to have a phd to be a clinical
psychologist yeah damn yeah
okay
yeah so yeah you spend a few too many
years
studying and yeah which you're used to
right um but yeah so you can train in
sort of one or two therapies or as a
counsellor from any profession
but um but yeah it's sort of purely
psychological therapies so is it i i i
know so little about psychological
therapy it's the sort of stuff that kind
of we refer people to clinical
psychologists but absolutely no idea
what they do so yeah apologies if this
seems like a dumb question but is it
that like you train in like
like 10 different therapies and then you
kind of pick the one that's appropriate
for the patient like
how does the training work yeah that's
probably the difference you'll find if
you if you sort of choose a clinical
psychologist over a different therapist
is they might be specialized in one
specific area whereas in the in the
clinical training you get you're
you're trained in lots of different
therapies depending on which university
you go to and stuff like that and then
you're equipped with those tools so you
can you know interchange you know use
different therapies for different
problems and um
yeah what is a therapy like how how have
they come up with like the different
therapies so
they've all come from from different
areas of research you know and they'll
be you know sort of um your behavioral
era where you know it was all about sort
of learning theory and and then you've
got sort of other areas of research that
looked at the impact of you know your
thought processes and and some other
bits of research combine those together
and and created this thing called cbt
that everyone sort of has heard about
and really that those kind of therapies
are about the link between
your thoughts your behaviors your
physical state and how you feel okay and
that you can't wake up in the morning
and just decide right today i want to
feel
love and joy you know you can't just
sort of directly
make them happen but we know that what
you feel is so heavily influenced by
those other aspects of your experience
so the focus of your attention what
you're doing or not doing your physical
state those sorts of things so we can
use those to then influence how you feel
on a day-to-day basis so
that's the sort of one therapy and there
are others that are based on research
around you know early life attachment
and then adult attachment or
relationships and those sorts of things
so
you know they all have sort of branched
out of different areas of research and
can be used for different problems but
often people come along with a whole
collection of problems you know it's not
sort of one specific thing probably
similar in medicine isn't it people come
with a whole collection of things going
on and they'll need um tackling with
different tools so um yeah so you have
like this arsenal of tools and you sort
of pick the appropriate one and because
you've got enough of a grounding in like
the main ones you can sort of carve your
own path through that that's going to
help help the patient or the client or
whatever yeah
how
scientific is therapy
well everything you know
through my doctorate everything
that we learnt or used had to be
evidence-based so you know we were
learned to kind of scrutinize the
research and
and justify everything that we were
doing based on uh you know research has
been done or when we were doing our own
research and things like that so yeah i
mean i think there is
maybe it's the sort of um
the sort of well-being industry that has
maybe sort of muddied the waters for
people a little bit where there's this
then lack of trust because people aren't
really sure like you say what is the
difference between a psychologist or a
counselor or another therapist or you
know there's this sort of
um people don't necessarily know because
they're not told what the difference is
and and uh who to trust or what
qualifications to look for and those
sorts of things so there's a real issue
there that perhaps could help people you
know when they're looking for help um
because often get people asking me those
questions you know i've got this this
problem or my son or daughter has these
problems where do we go who do we look
for what sort of therapy are we looking
for so i signed up to the school of life
therapy program like a few months ago
yeah just for the bands like
and i mentioned this to my mom so my
mom's a psychiatrist and she was like
there's no such thing as therapy just
for the bounce like what are you doing
she was like well you know when when you
go for therapy you have a specific
problem that you want a solution to and
then you want to find out what what
techniques the therapist using what form
of therapy is it are they using this or
this or that and i was like look man i
don't know um my boy alanda baton says
that everyone should get therapy and so
i'm just gonna try it and see what
happens
where do you stand on the spectrum of
like therapies for specific targeted
problems versus everyone can benefit
from therapy well you know yeah there is
a there is an argument for
um you know a problem with a specific
you know targeted set of tools and all
that kind of thing but actually
there's also a lot to be said for
building self-awareness and
self-reflection and and when we don't do
a lot of that and we don't build up
those skills to look back on things
reflect on things learn from experiences
and use them as we move forward then
we're missing a lot of opportunity for
development and growth and
self-awareness so you know often people
go to therapy when they don't feel
there's any other choice you know they
they just they get to a sort of rock
bottom or you know hit an end point and
think well i need to work this out now
but it's much harder to dig yourself out
of a a huge hole than you know crawl out
of a ditch isn't it so it's a sort of um
you know
i i think go for it okay interesting
yeah because my my my view of this was
always that like uh even if i have
nothing wrong like right now that i
don't know of at least let's just get a
let's just get a little like vibe check
um kind of like i don't know
prevention rather than cure yeah you can
only benefit from from anything you
learn from it and how are you finding it
so far is it so i i did like three or
four sessions and in each of those she
was like okay so what are we talking
about today i was like well you know
there's things on my mind we kind of
talked about it and after about three or
four sessions i found that like for the
subsequent one or two i was really
scraping the bottom of the barrel to
figure out what to talk about and so we
ended up stopping the sessions because
she was like well maybe you know you had
these things and we've solved them and
so there's no need to keep it keep it
going
so i'm not i'm not i'm not really sure
um
yeah does that vibe with your experience
yeah i mean it's interesting isn't it
sometimes they're
when you're sort of not sure what to
talk about you often think you're sort
of looking for a problem there has to be
a problem you're talking about rather
than any form of introspection at all or
um you know
learning about an experience or anything
like that so it's it's just interesting
to be able to and nice that you can go
back to it knowing that you don't need
to feel that you're really stuck with a
problem before you just look at
something and learn from it yeah yeah i
i kind of saw it a bit like so we've we
we've got a bunch of um business coaches
that are helping with like the
operations and stuff for the business
and i just rock up once a week and
they're like all right so what's on your
mind well we're having kind of this
issue with like a team member and then
just just sort of talking through it
with someone is just like enormously
helpful and so therapy kind of felt like
a business coach but for life
yeah lots of us go through life with a
bit of a love-hate relationship with
stem subjects in theory the idea of
learning how the world works in science
and learning how to build websites with
computer science is really awesome but
when you're plotting your way through
formulas in a science class or trying to
understand code it can be a bit dry and
boring the way i like to learn more
about this stuff in a fun and engaging
way is with brilliant with kindly
sponsoring this episode brilliant have a
ton of courses that teach maths science
and computer science with visual
examples and interactive challenges
along the way so that you can learn by
doing one of my favorite courses in
brilliant is actually the computer
science series especially the
introduction to algorithms and the
fundamentals of programming with python
i was actually considering applying for
computer science rather than medicine at
university and i ended up going down the
medicine route which i don't regret but
i never really understood computer
science and although i knew how to code
i didn't really understand the
foundational algorithms and structures
behind the field of computer science so
i really enjoyed checking out brilliant
courses on that and also their course on
cryptocurrency is absolutely sick and
without that course i really would not
have understood how bitcoin for example
works anyway if you want to improve your
math science and computer science then
head over to brilliant.org forward slash
deep dive and the first 200 people to
sign up via that link will get 20 off
the annual subscription to brilliant so
thank you very much brilliant for
sponsoring this video so you're working
as a clinical psychologist in the nhs
and for the ministry of defense and then
you started the private practice and now
you have three million followers on tick
tock like yeah how how did we get from
private practice as a clinical
psychologist to three million followers
on tech talk what was the story sure so
um
i yeah i once i had
three children i realized i couldn't do
it all well you know i was doing
part-time minute chairs part-time
private and i just couldn't manage it
all so i thought i could you know see a
few sort of private clients during
school hours and manage it really nicely
around the children so i sort of moved
into that that private work and then
during that time i had all these people
coming along
and a significant portion of some
therapies is quite educational so you
teach people a bit about how their mind
works um
how they can influence their mood and
emotions and energy levels or
relationships and how they can work out
what cycles they're stuck in and that
sort of thing
and a lot of people i found once they
had that education
they were raring to go they were
empowered by it and and there was a lot
of you know that's why the title of the
book is why has nobody told me this
before because so many people were
saying certain versions of that in terms
of you know how did i not learn this at
school it's not rocket science but it's
really made a difference to my life um
so
yeah it was you know all of these people
were coming along finding that stuff
really helpful
and then i was sort of harping onto my
poor husband saying how is this not
available you know why do people have to
pay to come and see me to find out um
because it's not therapy skills it's
life skills it's stuff we could all use
and stuff that i use to um say well as
well so it you know it's um
i i was sort of
talking about it to him and then he said
well okay make it available do it you
know put a video on youtube or something
and um
and so we did we started to kind of make
a couple of really cringy videos where i
was sort of you know trying to be
educational and um and at the same time
my husband discovered tick-tock and we
were instantly addicted to it it was
really fun and there was lots of dancing
and comedy and um
and he said well you know try and say
something in 60 seconds and put it on
there and my initial thought was no i
will get trolled out of there for sure
um but anyway
long story short is we had to go with
the idea that at any point we can delete
this and just forget it have happened um
but very very quickly within a couple of
weeks i think it was it just started to
kind of blow up and
that was november 2019
so it was a couple of months before the
lockdowns started to happen and stuff my
whole and the whole account was set up
with the idea of being useful and
putting some value in there i didn't
really have any interest of being a
public person in any way or that sort of
thing
so my idea was every video has to have
some sort of value to it at some point
that that could be shared
and the fact that people clicked follow
on an account that was purely about
mental health education
says a lot about what people need to
hear and what people are looking for i
think um
and the stuff that's just not you know
as readily available as or perhaps there
is lots of information out there but
there's also lots of misinformation out
there so people wanted to know that what
what they were hearing was you know
valid or research based and stuff like
that yeah so yeah it started to kind of
blow up very quickly i wonder if we can
just sort of zoom into the that moment
when you decided that you're gonna get
over the cringe and make that youtube
video make that tick tock what was that
experience like yeah you know it was
okay i i
hated the sound of my own voice so when
i would sort of listen back to them and
stuff um some of them i just handed over
to my husband matt said just press the
button and i'll sort of look this way
and then you know just didn't ever want
to see it again and
probably that's one of my methods
actually is just don't watch it back too
much because then you just become
critical and you want to make the
perfect video and actually it's better
off just saying
i know it's not perfect i might not look
or sound perfect but it's a useful
message so put it out there just in case
and then what you do is you get back
these messages from people saying
well thank you that really changed my
day or i'm using this with my son or
daughter and it's really helping thank
you and then you think well
yeah it's okay to put a non-perfect
video up there if you're being valuable
to someone so
that's sort of allowed me to
um
be imperfect yeah yeah and that that
kind of reminds me of the stuff you talk
about in motivation in in the book i
think it's maybe chapter two where you
say that it's really about like those
small steps and getting that feedback
and then that sustains the motivation
yeah it was that i guess that kind of
played into what kept you going in the
early days yeah and and in the book i
talk about that sort of need for
intrinsic motivation you know that sort
of we don't need uh you know they always
give stickers to kids now don't they at
schools and stuff
you know we don't need a sticker or a
trophy along the way we need uh
something inside of us that says yes
you're on the right track you're doing
the right thing and for me it was it was
that feeling that i get from
feedback from real people saying i used
it and it was helpful to me thank you um
and then there's that realization of you
know i can sit in one room with one
person at a time and try and be helpful
but when you can get
you know 100 messages back in a day that
say thank you that was really helpful
then
wow you know what an opportunity to
reach all those people were you worried
at all about your professional standing
when you started like yeah what was that
like there's a thing that all doctors
worry about as well so i i guess it's
the same yeah it's something i can ask
you as well actually because that was
probably the main thing in my mind was
oh what if someone i used to work with
sees this and what will they think of me
and and that sort of thing and and
you know somehow i managed to just do it
anyway but um
and actually the feedback i've got from
from old colleagues and staff has been
really positive you know sort of
colleagues who um
gps and stuff like that who say that
they you know mention the channel when
people are struggling and i think gosh
that that's
that's the compliment you want isn't it
is when people are willing to share your
stuff because they see it's valuable too
so and that's the sort of seal of
approval but there is just this moment
of almost free fall isn't it where you
think i'm gonna do it anyway and see
what happens and risk disapproval um but
i think i always had to stick to
that sense that
i'm doing it because i believe this
could be a useful thing for people yeah
i know there's this stuff that people
could have access to and um and we could
make it valuable for people so i had to
just sort of stick to my guns try and
maintain a sense of credibility all the
way along and um not just say anything
you know do my research and make sure
that things were grounded in
an evidence-based and stuff like that so
so that i believed in it yeah i think
that's that's really it's it's sort of
like um the whole simon sonic stuff the
whole start start with why thing like
when you have that core why behind what
you're doing it's not that you're trying
to get famous it's not that you're
trying to become a tick-tock celebrity
it's that you're trying to educate
people on something that's genuinely
useful yeah i guess that is
oh you know that's the intrinsic
motivation rather than the extrinsic oh
i want to hit a million followers and
stuff like that yeah and it's it's
difficult because it it grabs you
doesn't and these platforms are made to
be
um addictive for creators as well as
users so there is a sense of oh how many
views did we get there or how many views
did we get there but always being able
to pull it back to
why did i make that video and actually
i've noticed that if i make a video
that i'm particularly pleased with
because it's valuable information i want
to share
i care a bit less about how many views
it gets because i think if i if that
video helps 10 people
but only gets seen by you know 10 000
then that's that's worth it for me but
if if another video i make is not so
valuable but i'm doing it to try and get
views
then it's got less of a reward for me if
i um you know if i start to go down that
road yeah yeah it's exactly the same on
the youtube video thing like um
every creator i've ever spoken to has
this constant struggle between caring
about the numbers while simultaneously
not caring about the numbers how do you
how do you tell that line i just think
it's a tightrope isn't it and you always
have to just um
do a bit of a sort of mental check-in
every now and then
because i can tell if i start to go down
that road i mean
my husband is really that kind of side
of it so he'll look at numbers and say
oh this didn't do well that did well and
things like that but i feel that if i
get
um too into that then it's not good
because it really stumps creativity and
my ability to to think from from the
word go about what am i going to put
together to make a video with um you
know if i'm only thinking about views
um
it's just so much harder to do the whole
thing um
but i mean that's where i found your
channel so so helpful and and such an
inspiration really was because you were
sort of putting so much value into each
into each video you know when you kind
of do book reviews and things like that
you just start opening it you can give
everything just talk about it all and
what was useful and what was not useful
and those kind of things and that's
really sort of where i like to come from
is just you know just give the the value
and then we'll try to sew it up for
something that is vaguely entertaining
afterwards
um yeah yeah like so i've i had a bit of
a a crisis a couple of months ago where
um we put out a video on the channel and
had to delete it because it was just
like
50 dislikes loads of comments being like
this is like really just genuinely bad
content and it kind of led me on this
sort of journey of introspection of
realizing that i'd gone too far in the
direction of you know i i preached
consistency and like hey one video a
week for many many years and i'd still
been clinging
four and a half years later i've been
clinging on to this idea that i have to
put out two videos every single week and
we need to put that video there because
there's a sponsored deadline and
eventually that got to the point where i
was like oh you know really scraping the
bottom of the barrel in terms of video
content ideas
and genuinely putting stuff out for the
sake of it rather than because it was
valuable
and so i was like okay let's just take a
step back and really examine this
assumption why do i feel the need to
actually put out two videos a week
and then i decided you know what let's
now not be beholden to any upload
schedule and only put out a video if i
think it's actually good or if i think
you know people will like it in some
capacity like i know you've done a few
videos that are more about like you
rather than about like the educational
side which go down really well because
people then start to care about you as a
person um
and so in the last couple of months
we've actually not published that many
videos but the channel is growing faster
than ever before because the only ones
we've been putting out are the ones that
i've internally felt i'm actually proud
of this video i think this is genuinely
good yeah um and to your point like when
when i hit when i hit publish on a video
that i fully feel is genuinely good i
don't care about the numbers anymore
because it's like this is this is
actually a sick video like if people
like it great if they don't that's
totally fine yeah i think i think it's
great and that's so refreshing to hear
that someone you know with as many
followers as you and that you know this
huge channel
can also put out a video and go oh gosh
it's performing really badly you know
take it off so i mean
it's so human then isn't it to say it
happens to everybody and you know
because i've done the same where we've
put a video everything oh actually no
this is not going down well you know
just just it's not quite right we got it
wrong somehow and and it's okay to do
that you know i like this idea of
not putting across this sort of i think
that's something that can happen as well
being a psychologist people think you
must have it all sorted you must just
you know be motivated all the time or
you must um you know never have a
problem or you know never have anything
you don't feel you can deal with and
actually
it that's the sort of side of social
media that i try to steer back stay back
from and i'm a human being and it's
really important to sort of show people
that we all make mistakes or we all
struggle sometimes and and it's all
right because we're all human and you
know
um number of followers or anything
doesn't make any difference really nice
um speaking of number four so um so you
started about two years ago november
2019 yeah um and we're now we're now at
three million so what was the growth
trajectory like so it started to grow
really fast i think there was a point
that in sort of the early first couple
months we were going about sort of
um
anything up to sort of a hundred
thousand a month and then in lockdown i
think that the biggest month when
everybody you know locked down and
switched on tick tock was a sort of i
think our biggest we put out a sort of
really big viral video and i think we
had about quarter of a million in a
month but that was a sort of one-off and
then it sort of steadied out and and um
uh yeah so and we just sort of tipped
over three million
a couple of weeks ago i think it was so
it's been steady going and then and then
also sort of branching out to you know
other platforms and um
places like instagram where you can
really sort of engage your followers and
be in your stories and stuff like that
but also i think i you know
the 60 second videos or the 15 second
videos
are great for grabbing people's
attention but there was a part of me as
well that wanted to be really valuable
and give all that detail and that's
really what the book is about is is
giving all those extra details about
okay well if there is this concept that
can help how do you do it here's step
one here's step two and here's that
theory behind it and here's the research
that's based in um so that's really
where the book came in about giving all
of that detail so that people could go
to it as a resource
um and structured in terms of problems
as well you know that
you don't especially when you're
struggling you don't want to read a book
cover to cover you want to be able to go
to the bit you find helpful or the
problem you're dealing with
and work it out straight away so i tried
to sort of structure it like that as
well so it's just a real resource for
people yeah no i really like that
approach to it like i looked at the
table of contents and i went straight to
meaningful life because i was like this
is currently the problem it's like
motivation
we like sort of that years ago let's go
into the meaningful lifestyle towards
the end of the book you've got a whole
section called um
on a meaningful life people have been
trying to answer this question for like
millennia so what what's the kind of
psychology recent scientific take on
what how how do we live a meaningful
life sure so a lot of the stuff from
that section is taken from i really like
using um acceptance and commitment
therapy act um which has a whole um
sort of part of that therapy is around
understanding your own values and what
gives you meaning and purpose in life
and
yeah so i've devoted a whole section to
it because i think it's so so important
and i also think it's important to
not just do it once but to keep doing
sort of little values check-ins where
you you just step back get a bit of a
bird's eye view on what's going on in
your life at this point what matters
most to you at this point because it
changes right you know what was
important to you at 21 might not be the
same things that are important to you at
31. so your values change as you go
along but the way um that we set it out
in therapy is is that
a value is like
a path
that you follow your whole life there is
no end to it but you just you value that
part so you want to stay close to it as
much as you can so a goal is something
you
once you've done it you you've done it
it's finished so your
your goal might be to do a marathon but
your value might be to stay fit and
healthy
and so the marathon becomes one of many
possible goals along the way but your
value is to
to continue to be fit and healthy along
the way
so that's the path yeah it's fitting how
you know fitness and health yeah um and
then there can be lots of lots of
hurdles and lots of goals along the way
um
but at times life steers you away from
those so you know you might life happens
and maybe your job is very intense or
you have children or whatever it is and
it might stay away from that path and so
that's why i think it's so important to
do these regular
sort of values check-ins where you go
oh i'm not feeling quite right and
actually lots of people come to therapy
with that sort of sense of i'm not
really sure what the problem is i just
i'm feeling a bit lost or a bit you know
life feels a bit meaningless at the
moment and often that's because people
have lost touch with what's most
important to them or life has steered
them away from things that matter to
them
and so just getting clarity on what does
matter to me what is the most important
thing or things in my life at the moment
and what kind of person do i want to be
in those areas of my life
which then allows you to
set goals
based on the life that you want to have
or the person that you want to be how
how do you go about figuring out your
values
so there are lots of kind of little
exercises you do you can do
uh sometimes you can literally just grab
a piece of paper
um separate into little boxes you might
have boxes for um family life or
lifelong learning or
health or creativity so you can kind of
fill those boxes with different aspects
of your life and then in each box kind
of ask yourself
what kind of person do i want to be in
this area of my life so
maybe it's family relationships
what kind of son do i want to be to my
mum what kind of my dad and you know
what what kind of relationship do i want
to have
what do i want to represent to those
people
how would that show up in terms of
behavior and action you know daily
behavior um and you just kind of fill it
with with words or bullet points and
that gives you this this
picture of what life would be like if
you were living in line with all of
those values and sometimes they pull on
each other so sometimes they conflict
you know you might have this um real
idea of being a
um
you know successful entrepreneur but
actually that sucks all of your time and
you also want to be a family guy and you
want to spend time with your kids or you
know and so often there's this idea you
know this sort of this balancing act
where okay life has pulled me in one
direction and i want to pull it back
this way so it's not about
setting goals and doing them perfectly
it's about always just tipping the
balance um you know i haven't been
working out for a while because i've
been so focused on work so i know i'm
just going to come back in this
direction a little bit more and and
balance things out
so it's really just getting clarity
but it's also not not focusing on um
what happens to you so it's not saying
this is what i want in my life because
then things can happen and then you
think failed it hasn't worked out it's
really not it's really not about what
happens to you it's about
how you want to be
in the face of all the stuff that life
throws at us how do i want to respond
when hard stuff happens how do i want to
respond when i'm in a good place um and
stuff like that yeah as you were saying
this was like damn these are some really
good questions i should i should sit
down
um so is that like so
in in one of the early drafts of my book
proposal uh the first chapter was going
to be about like values and like meaning
and stuff and after doing a bunch of
stuff and like reading an act textbook
and things i realized okay let me
leave this aside for now maybe this is
book three or four or five ten years
down the line when
20 or 30 years down the line when i have
more experience let's stick to the thing
that i actually can feasibly talk about
which is like productivity and fun and
stuff um and so i came across a bunch of
these sort of value finding value
funding exercises uh so i've kind of
figured out what some of my values are i
think
but knowing that
and then actually
using it to change a decision that i
would have made otherwise
i haven't really done much of that like
how
let's say someone does these journaling
prompts and figures out okay i want to
be the sort of
son that does xyz i want to be the sort
of parent that does xyz
how do you how do you translate that
into physical like actual action yeah
that's where you know the therapy stuff
can be really helpful because it's a
protected time in the week where you are
going to reflect on
those values and the things that you
want to work on
so they're not necessarily a big problem
but it's a direction you want to steer
to and so it becomes this place where
you're accountable to that and you go
and reflect on um in hindsight and
that's where it all begins is looking
back on things so you think okay here's
my map of you know all these different
values i have and things that are
important to me how how am i living in
line with them and you know how have i
been living in line with them in the
last two weeks
or have i you know and and
when when you look back and you think
gosh i really haven't
what would i need to do
to steer back towards that value or to
steer back towards that path
um
and then it creates a mini goal for the
week ahead you know and and that's
really how therapy works is you know you
go and you have this sense of
accountability for yourself yeah you
um there are things you want to work on
and you see how you've been getting on
and
you tweak things a bit and you set a new
goal for the next week and then and then
you reflect on that again next week so i
think translating kind of ideas and
values into action
is really about
reflection and planning so you you learn
in hindsight you look back actually yeah
if i'm really really honest with myself
in the last couple of weeks have i been
living in line with that value yeah
whatever it was enthusiasm for example
and then
you know if if the answer is not really
you create a set of
you know specific actions that i will do
this week
to to move closer to that and then the
next week you reflect on well how was
that did it move me closer does that
feel enough do i need to do more do i
need to step back and those sorts of
things so it's just a always balancing
and tweaking and
never ever doing it perfectly because
that's really not the aim
yeah i really like that model of like
it's like you're steering towards this
path that you've kind of decided that
this is the thing i care about for now
yeah um do values change much as we grow
older oh hugely i think yeah um
i mean
for me i i you know when i was i don't
know 19 or 20 i never even envisioned
myself as as being a parent i was really
focused on my studies and learning and
traveling and doing all those things um
but now that's without a doubt the most
important thing in my life so you know
that it's only a decade it's only you
know um
uh
you know it's it's not a long time but
but when life throws things at you and
life changes then you you know what what
matters to you changes as well and
that's okay you know you don't have to
be the same person yeah you learn and
grow and you would adapt to that i think
nice so
coming back to the overall question of
like
meaningful life it sounds like figuring
out your values is like a pretty
reasonable first step on the path of
like hey i know i mean we all basically
know that we want to live a meaningful
life but i think
very few of us actually
keep that in mind yeah when because it's
just it's it's kind of a bit a bit weird
like it's a bit out there to think oh
what's the meaning of life okay well let
me do some exercises and actually figure
this out rather than just dismissing it
as oh no one can ever figure that out
kind of thing yeah and i think we often
look outwards as well don't we we look
to
you know we're bombarded with media that
tell us what
life should be about and what our
purpose should be
and
um
it's quite empowering when you give
yourself permission to
generate your own meaning and say well
actually you know
it is up to you what matters to you and
then you can structure life around that
life's still really really hard and
there are still responsibilities but how
you approach those responsibilities it's
really your choice um
and and that can be quite sort of
refreshing i think i think you don't
have to be gaining everybody's approval
you have to be looking at well
what would life be like if i approved of
myself if i approved of myself oh i was
in like if i were kind of following the
path that i've decided is meaningful
yeah so if i'm looking for my own
approval what what would i be doing you
know it's a sort of yes we can get
approval from other people but also
what would make me really pleased with
myself because those are my values
rather than necessarily being other
peoples can you really dissociate that
like
you know let's say i value
i'm i'm considering applying to harvard
for like an mba
and i keep on like second-guessing this
because i'm like why am i doing this
like i value prestige i value status i
value these badges of like
stuff is that really like me or is that
kind of what society plus or minus my
family have kind of instilled in to me
that makes me feel as if it's coming
from within if that makes sense
what's what's the gut feeling what's do
you feel that it's
come from outside no
i don't feel like it's come from outside
but i also didn't come out of the womb
thinking i want to i want to get a
degree from cambridge
so there is some level of like you know
it wasn't a genetic decision there is
some level of like socialization that
goes into this sort of stuff yeah and i
guess i wondered to what extent
the fact that
i know that probably a large chunk of my
identity is socialized in some to some
degree does that still make me
me or does it make me a product of my
the society i've been brought up in and
then how do i like find my true meaning
if
well it's society that's told me that a
harvard and cambridge degree is like a
good thing does that make sense yeah
absolutely because we're all a product
of our upbringings and our cultures and
all those kind of things aren't we so
you know i don't think it's about sort
of finding this one truth i think it's
about creating the meaning and holding
on to things that you know
what a wonderful thing that would be to
do if that was what you would enjoy and
find inspiring and exactly so you know i
think you can that's the beauty of it is
um when
when you're in a position
that you can choose those things
then you can decide um yes it might be
that i've i've learned
you know some of these sort of um ideas
around prestige of universities and
stuff
but actually i would really enjoy that
and it would give me a lot of meaning
and purpose it doesn't matter if if it
came from someone else if you agree with
it you know
whereas if you feel that's good
pressured and it's not something you
want to do but you feel like you're
doing it because
you know someone will disapprove of you
if you don't and that's slightly
different isn't it yeah but if it's
something you love
and you would get good memories from and
i think i think it's kind of like
like realistically the reason i go to
the gym is not for myself it's to look
more attractive
but i also agree that it's a good thing
to do and therefore who cares what the
prime motivation is it's a good thing to
do exactly you can kind of use all the
different aspects of pressure and to
your own advantage um are there values
that are more better than others
like and like like for example if i
would be like okay you know really my
value is sitting in front of the
playstation playing video games all day
yes you could say well any anything goes
as long as it makes you happy but
there's also
i'm sure there must be some evidence
around like well i don't know
relationships or like whatever as as
focusing on these things even if you
feel like you don't really want to in
the moment because you're focused on
video games will actually be good for
you in the long term is there like that
aspect when it comes to values of some
being like better if we're optimizing
for a meaningful life
yeah because i think um
you know your value might be i don't
know
um
time out and rest or you know your value
might be around there might be even to
do with um you know your well-being if
you have your really stressful job and
that's always been time to sort of
unwind for you then it would fit whereas
you know playing videos all the time
um might actually pull you away from a
lot of your other values so
you know it can be really tempting and
that's where these subjects are really
difficult to kind of grasp and
and be concrete with because they're so
sort of broad and there is no set
prescription
um there is maybe that temptation to
kind of um make it your own make it
whatever you suits what you want to do
at the time and and actually a lot of
having a meaningful life is about
being responsible you know taking on
responsibility and accountability
for
um
anyone you're responsible for or things
you're responsible or things that you
believe in um and doing the hard stuff
it's not necessarily about um
doing whatever whatever feels good now
it's do you know that that's when we get
into a lot of trouble is i think is when
we we base our actions on how we want to
feel now as opposed to how we want to
feel in the future
um because you might really enjoy
playing computer computer games non-stop
five years down the road you might look
back and think oh god yeah i really want
to do that you know um yeah i think
there is a balance there between like
not being so future focused that we
forget to live in the present yeah but
also not being so present focused that
like the whole if every day like it's
your last it's like probably terrible
advice yeah um because then you'd just
be doing heroin
like destroying yourself exactly in a
meaningful purposeful life is often
about you know doing the hard stuff for
the benefit of you know your future or
someone else's future or your community
and yeah all of those things yeah the
the way i've been thinking about it
recently is i mean it's all kind of
semantics but like
happiness is how good i'm feeling in the
moment broadly and like contentment and
meaning is
how useful i am being to other people
um i don't know does that like
make sense at all from
what what you've read and written about
the stuff yeah because i think there's a
you know this sort of happiness
movement was was really um
it's a tricky one isn't it because it's
it's
a feeling like any other that comes and
goes and we can't depend on it and but i
think um when so much was sort of
written about happiness as this thing
that we all needed to sort of grab and
hold on to
it then
it gave us the impression that that
happiness is our default mode and
anything out of that could be a mental
health problem right and so you know
that this idea that
you can everyone has bad days right
everyone has days when they don't feel
happy
um they feel something else and and
that's normal and that's human and
that's okay
um and actually some of the things that
make us happiest also make us feel lots
of really negative and painful emotions
so i don't know like uh what you know
when you become a parent you feel that's
the the you know best thing in the world
to you and you feel really happy but
also there will be times when you feel
really really sad and and ashamed if you
feel like you've made some mistake or um
you know distressed when your child goes
out into the world or you know there's a
whole host of emotions that come along
with happiness as well so um
yeah
it's it's a shame how sort of
oversimplified it it kind of has been
made i think so so we kind of said that
living meaningful life is sort of like
figuring out what your values are and
then attempting to live
sort of in in alignment with those
values
um are there any other kind of uh
elements that add into the recipe or the
the thing of a meaningful life beyond
the value stuff yeah i think it it's
it's keeping in touch with those values
isn't it on a regular basis so that
so that you don't find yourself adrift
and and wondering what
on earth is the meaning if any or you
know when when because i think life
starts to feel a bit meaningless doesn't
it if if we
um don't really have clarity on
why we're doing what we're doing and
yeah and all of those things so i guess
it's sort of um keeping in touch with
those
those values and
and trying to be around people whose
whose values connect in some way i think
you can suddenly feel very alone if if
you find yourself in a situation where
your values clearly do not
cross over with the people that you're
around
so there's you know you can't really
talk about a meaningful life without
talking about relationships as well and
how to manage relationships
um
so yeah i mean there's a section in the
book on on or there's a chapter in the
book on relationships within the
meaningful life because you can't you
can't really separate the two um we're
social beings so you know
relationships are our meaning really
what
what can we do to kind of live more in
alignment with that i mean because i
guess because
at least speaking for me
i know intellectually that relationships
are the most important thing in life
and yet if i think about like all the
podcasts i listen to 98 of them are
about business and two of them are about
health and relationships and if i think
about how i spend my time like 16 hours
a day spent here doing like the youtube
stuff and like one or two hours i spent
hanging out with friends like
if that makes sense like yeah that so
that
i i know intellectually that actually
relationships are important and yet i
didn't call my mum this morning like
yeah yeah and and that in itself is just
interesting isn't it when we look
because i think there's perhaps a
tendency to
um when we when we look at that to them
be self-critical and think oh i'm not
getting it right or you know i need to
do and and actually it has to come with
that sort of reflection has to come with
some compassion that um we are set up in
a world that that dictates that we go to
work for certain hours a day and
you know certain days a week and all
these kind of things and and we are
wrapped up in that um but it what an
amazing privilege to be able to sort of
get a bird's-eye view on it look at it
and say i'd like it to be a bit
different could is it possible in with
my life situation at the moment to make
it any different or to tip the balance
and the reality is for a lot of people
they have to be at work for a certain
number of hours a day or you know those
kind of things and life is really tough
um but when
we get into a position where we have
choices
how empowering to be able to use them
and to say do you know what you know i'm
ali abdel now and
friday afternoon
and that would be great you know
but the the pressure that is a cultural
pressure i think isn't it to you know
this sort of burnout badge of honor type
thing that i work work and and you know
earn more be more buy more all of that
kind of stuff that inevitably leads to
you know lots of people
um queuing up outside the therapy room
door yeah
yeah that's a question i sometimes ask
myself like
what is the point of all of this more
um kind of moving to london getting this
ridiculously expensive studio building a
team to freaking 17 people now it's so
it all feels i sometimes look back and i
think huh
how the hell do we get here but then at
the same time i think okay but this like
genuinely feels fun like if i
if i think of how i'd want to spend the
next 12 months of my life i i could kind
of do whatever i could like travel the
world and stuff but it genuinely does
feel more stuff and more fun to be like
actually actually i just want to come
into the studio every day just hang out
with the team and like make cool make
cool videos and maybe that preference
will change further down the line yeah
but right now that's the thing that
feels the most fun
and so let's just give it a go and see
what happens yeah absolutely and it's
giving you you know opportunities and
great experiences and you're meeting
different people and and so if you value
those things at that point and it feels
that it's giving you joy and some
meaning and some purpose and then why
not you know it's okay to say this
doesn't have to be forever i can do this
while it feels meaningful yeah and then
it's okay at some point if my values or
meaning change you know it's um
it's kind of taking each chapter for
what it is yeah i really like that like
most decisions are i mean other than
like marriage and kids and stuff are
kind of temporary um like you know this
is a one-year lease on this building so
it's a one-year experiment yeah and then
we'll see what happens yeah
it kind of takes the pressure off it a
little bit
um that the way that the thing that
we're doing now is not the thing that we
actually have to do forever which is the
thing that we're doing for now yeah and
we're just checking with ourselves and i
find that you know over the last couple
of weeks i've been finding something
doesn't feel quite right and i look at
my calendar i'm like well it's full of
all of these meetings and stuff and
really i want to carve out more time for
writing all right cool i i just can't do
that so no more meetings before 12 p.m
all right team sort the rest out and now
i have writing time in the morning and
it's great please um i just feel it
feels nice to
kind of give myself the permission to do
that yeah because i was operating before
and i'm just default mode just not
realizing that i can sort of carve the
life that i think i want and experiment
that with that for a couple of weeks and
see what happens and correct course yeah
i sort of thought i had to sort of get
it perfect from from day one but it's
it's nice to have the freedom to just
like explore yeah because there is that
pressure isn't there to sort of um have
it all sorted and appear to have it all
sorted which then holds us back from
uh learning and changing direction
um a bit like you know even in sort of
medicine or in psychology if if at any
point it doesn't feel safe to to make a
mistake or anything then then you become
sort of almost defensive in in your
practice don't you and you kind of think
um it's not okay to learn from
experience and do something differently
next time i have to show that i've got
it all sorted so i think there is a lot
of that in our
society isn't there that um that stops
people from
just making it small changed and giving
themselves permission to do that because
it would make them happier as you're
growing on tech talk on instagram and
kind of dabbling with youtube where did
the book come into things like what was
the story behind how the book came to be
it was it was in my mind that that i
wanted to give more details and more you
know how to's to make it as useful as it
could be for people
um
but it wasn't until i got approached by
my literary agent abigail bergstrom who
was really really helpful you know i was
having all these sort of publishers get
in contact
um with ideas and things that he wanted
to do
but she really helped by saying
write the book that you want to write so
you know put together the proposal for
the thing that you want to do and then
we'll take it from there and and you
know send that out to people so and then
uh and then sign the deal with penguin
which was just really really exciting um
and it was writing through through
lockdown so
my poor husband was trying to homeschool
three children while i was locked
upstairs trying to get the you know 80
000 words out which again was a huge
rollercoaster emotionally because you
you're taken completely out of
your comfort zone or the place where you
feel like you know what you're doing and
started um i got a few book
recommendations from your videos
actually about writing and things like
that um
and you know
i just started reading a lot about
writing thinking oh my gosh i know the
psychology but how do i put it across in
the right way and um so that was that
was a real experience was was
how do i write you know um
that i'm i've got this this this deal
because i've got this audience how do i
make it really really good um so that
people can be engaged by it and stuff
how did you find your literary agent
really really helpful
how did you find her oh how did i find
it so i was approached by gleam futures
who are a management company yeah so um
i work with them and they um sort of
help me with the different brand deals
and events and things that i'll join and
um she was the head of published their
in-house publishing she's now sort of
branched out on her own i think um but
yeah they sort of found me i was in the
weirdly i was in the evening standard on
some article
and during lockdown it was being
delivered to people's houses
and so uh one of the girls um
that was quite sort of high up in gleam
saw the the
article and then gave me a call and said
what a new management um but they've
been absolutely really really helpful in
helping me to kind of steer this health
in because it's
completely new to me um
i'm just sort of stepping out of the
therapy room and going i don't know what
i'm doing or where i'm taking this so it
was really really helpful to have a bit
of guidance oh nice and so
when you so then you kind of put the
proposal together
how how different was the proposal to
what ended up being the final product
it's similar in terms of how it's
structured
i perhaps didn't have a really set idea
of
what would be in each chapter i kind of
had this idea of yeah i'll cover this
this and this and then oh the mountain
of research came after you know um
and yeah i think that there wasn't a day
when my desk wasn't absolutely covered
in paper and books and
you know notes and things like that it
was a monstrous task but um
what an experience and i mean how is
your book going are you still working on
still so we've uh
the proposal is now finished like a year
later yeah and it's like the proposal
went through so many iterations and it
completely scrapped the concept and then
when it went down a whole different
different route
um now i'm into the actual writing and
i've realized that it's it's very easy
to make promises in the proposal
like in chapter one i will discuss the
importance of goal setting and why goals
should be like this rather than that and
why motivation is about this rather than
that like that was actually writing it's
like bloody hell
i made a big promise
to actually deliver on it looking at the
research like oh well actually the
research says the challenging goals are
better than easy goals and my whole
point is that easy goals are the way
forward dab
am i trying to make a point that's like
not with the research and then looking
into it and
um
yeah it's a
but it's fun it's it's sort of like
being back at uni almost where it's like
i'm trying to make a specific argument
throughout this essay and i just need to
find the evidence to back it up and make
sure i am not cherry-picking egregiously
to the point that it's actually
inaccurate um yeah yeah what was that
like it's a similar challenge isn't it
because we're probably quite similar in
the sense that i i really enjoy the
learning part and i enjoy the reading
and the and the discovery
and and then the real challenge for me
is okay try and put this into something
vegan coherent and engaging for people
and that always feels like the hard part
that i love is the oh let's read and
let's get all these books together and
find something there's such potential in
that um it's putting it together with
your experience and you you know things
that you've read
again so these arms they're just going
everywhere
um yeah so
um i love the sort of learning part and
and bringing it all together
um and then sort of
you know
going off on one in the kitchen to my
husband about this either this this and
this and this but actually writing it
down is a whole other ball game isn't it
um so yeah i find it super challenging
really challenging how how er
did you have any imposter syndrome
around the write writing the book every
day every day um
because what uh what was the book that
you recommended i've got it uh is it the
war of art oh
oh it's such a good book and i had to
sort of keep listening to i got the
paper version and the audiobook version
so that i could occasionally listen to
his voice uh reminding me that you know
a professional sits down and cracks on
um because there at that first sort of
hour or two of the day was really
getting over that hump of
can i do this am i am i should i even be
here writing this should somebody else
be doing it would somebody else have a
better place doing it and then reminding
yourself that you have all of this stuff
to share that people are finding useful
um and here we go okay yeah there's
nothing better than finding yourself
sort of 20 minutes into typing you think
yes yes i'm doing it i'm doing oh no no
i'm back just go on and you stop again
and you're kind of i'm worried about the
next bit but um
yeah just another one of those
experiences where you think um
i learned a lot from it because it was
such a challenge for me
yeah i think um in basically all of the
chats that i ever have with my agent and
editor they feel more like therapy
sessions where they're like look it's
okay you can do this trust yourself yeah
and i was like but it's a book and i'm
like yeah but a book's not that big a
deal like you know if you were making a
video about this topic you'd be pretty
comfortable like yeah have that same
energy when it comes to the book like
yeah but it's a book like
a book feels like such a big deal um i
don't know if you had any of that at all
like yeah well what did book feel like
relative to making a tick tock but yeah
i mean books are
my favorite thing in the world so it's a
it's a bit of a sort of running joke at
home actually that um you know i sort of
hoard books and they're very special to
me and i won't kind of throw them away
or that kind of thing and and and so
yeah to me
producing a book is such a such a
special thing to do and um
and there's so much potential every time
you pick up a book either the things
that you could learn or that has the
potential to change your day or your
life and um
so for me then it perhaps gave me this
sense of this has to be life-changing
and groundbreaking and and while i
believe that all this research was
learning about is life-changing and
groundbreaking and should be passed on
um
it's still then
then getting yourself to the point where
you think this book can be you know um
and i've i put you know blood sweat and
tears into
including the stuff that i think
has been so helpful for me and for the
people i've worked with um
that can
just generally help you get through
those normal day-to-day problems that we
all face you know there's a section on
grief a section on anxiety and um
you know motivation and those low days
that everybody gets so it wasn't really
on
disorders or you know really sort of
there isn't a section on depression for
example but there is a section on low
mood and dark times which everybody
faces you know everyone has those low
days
and then how can we how can we
understand those and how can we then do
something about it um
so yeah i was just trying to be kind of
as useful as possible um one thing you
talk about in the book is the idea of
motivation and like doing things even
when you don't feel like it
how how did you go about writing the
book even on days where you didn't feel
like it there were lots of days when i
probably didn't feel like it um
especially when i was missing out on
family time um because you know my job
was originally set up to be so that i
could be a mum for a lot of the time and
suddenly i had this deadline and i had
to be on this book all the time yeah
um there were a couple of weekends and
stuff where i you know the kids were
going out and to the park with my
husband and stuff and i was at home
feeling kind of sorry for myself and
those were the times when i really
didn't want to do it then it's using
those old therapy skills of sort of um
opposite action and stuff like that so
this so this idea that you can um well i
saw your video on that sort of
activation uh energy and stuff like that
yeah and it's really it's really similar
to um something we use in a therapy
called dbt dialectical behavior therapy
where we talk about opposite action so
the idea that you can have an urge to do
something and we get a choice whether we
act opposite to that urge or whether we
go with it and so and you can kind of
practice i mean we used to actually
without knowing we used to practice as
kids with like um polo mints and stuff
where you would have to hold a polo in
your mouth and not crunch it and the
urge to crunch and bite down on the mint
was really intense but then actually
when you do that you notice that you can
have an urge to do something
and you don't have to go with it you can
do something else you can act opposite
to it and so you can kind of practice
with sort of simple things like that
just to build up that self-awareness but
you know the urge might be to go down
and make a third cup of tea in the last
you know 45 minutes what's really going
on here is i'm i don't want to type
because i feel like it's going to be
terrible so i'm going to just going to
start knowing it's terrible and then at
some point i get into a grieve and i
forget that i'm you know trying to
not do this um so yeah the act opposite
was really is always really really
helpful for me actually um
not easy but
when you do manage to to use it it's
helpful yeah um
one thing that you write about as well
is how motivation is tied to identity i
wonder if you can kind of elaborate on
that a little bit yeah so i think if you
um if you see something as a a part of
who you are it seems to take less energy
if you clean your teeth every morning
because you see see yourself as someone
who looks after their dental hygiene
then it doesn't feel negotiable it's
just something you do you don't do it
because you feel like it today you do it
because that's what you do and it's just
a part of your life so um
yeah i think identity is a big part of
the things that we do you know we do
things because we've always done them
and so that's how they then become a
part of our identity that's something
that's been part of our lives for a long
time
so
um
yeah having something that
that you decide is a part of your
identity
it's not easy again it's not easy all of
these things are really easy for me to
say i say that a lot in therapy this is
really easy for me to say really really
hard to do in practice because it is
um but if you can sort of you know and
when like you say when you're going to
therapy for something that doesn't feel
like a problem actually when you're
trying to make some sort of positive
change in your life or redirect habits
and stuff sitting down and thinking
about your identity you know why is
changing this particular habit really
hard for me actually my identity is is
um based on something else or you know
it conflicts with it in some way
then you know maybe your identity is
that you work harder than anybody else
but then actually you're not making time
to go to the gym and stay healthy so if
you kind of then incorporate being a
healthy person into your identity it
becomes
a bit easier to prioritize it because
it's a part of who you are um and you
get to realize that you can do both yeah
yeah that's a pretty good point i think
that
so i when i when i first read atomic
habits and he talks a lot about kind of
ultimately habit change is like a thing
but really we're trying to go for
identity change yeah and i started
thinking of myself as i am i'm a person
who is healthy um and then it became
easier to make certain decisions around
going for one food versus another uh and
it's still not perfect like this morning
i was meant to have a personal trainer
session but i kind of got out of bed a
bit late i was doing an interview until
late night i was like oh i don't really
feel like it i was like do i cancel or
do i not and i ended up canceling the
session because i was like it's fine
it's all good
um but i think
i think also when it comes to identity
uh one thing that i found is that like
for for people who are interested in
like getting things done and
productivity and like self-improvement
and all that stuff
there is kind of a sort of
super identity in a way that sits above
the specific
identities which is sort of like a
i'm a person that gets things done i'm a
productive person i'm a sort of
whatever
that that means that kind of anything
underneath that which is basically
everything else in life becomes easier
to do whereas i find with people who
have told themselves that they are a
procrastinator oh i'm just so
unproductive oh i could never do that
it becomes so hard to then do all of the
other things like health and wealth and
like caring about relationships like all
of the other stuff around what makes a
good life is harder to do if you have an
identity of someone who does not have
their [ __ ] together
proverbially i don't know if that's
something that you've found at all yeah
absolutely you can have set sort of core
beliefs about yourself from from that
came from you know maybe early in
childhood and they've just persisted and
then and they can really we don't think
about them all the time so we're not
always even aware of them you know in
therapy we'll spend sometimes a fair
amount of time sort of trying to work
out what those core beliefs are for
someone and i'm really sort of trying to
get right down to it and once we get
there there's so often this sort of
light bulb moment people where they
think yes and because you don't really
think about your core beliefs
all the time sometimes never at all
but they're that template that was
perhaps set up for you early in life
that is
is your template for the world so it's
your idea of
they're often i am statements so
um it might be i don't know if it was
something negative it might be i am
unlovable or i am
um unlikable or something or it might be
what to expect from other people so
other people will
abandon me or other people will
you know um hurt me or something or
something about the world so the world
is a dangerous place or something like
that so those those core beliefs are the
things that kind of sit under the
surface and influence the choices that
we make but we don't necessarily
consciously think about why we're making
those choices we have an urge and we go
with it because we always did
um so so yeah that's sort of all of that
identity stuff it's a big part of what
happens in therapy but we can do that
kind of thing um
in a self-help approach so with
journaling and things like that you know
you can really reflect on some of your
own
you know choices or the the cycles that
you seem to get stuck in and you're not
really sure how to break it
getting it down on paper something we do
in therapy a lot is getting a bird's eye
view you literally draw maps of um
behavior patterns and and then you look
down and you go
oh that's how i can break it there's
there's the exit okay now i know what i
need to do um which can be really
helpful so there's a lot of that in the
book where there's a lot of things like
journal prompts they're just questions
for you to sit down and go okay
let's answer these in 10 minutes and
maybe you might have that moment when
you go
ah okay yeah i think journaling prompts
are such an underrated like
technique because like i i've i've come
across a lot of journal problems and as
i was reading through the book i was
like oh these prompts are really good
and then i didn't do anything with them
but i know if i just sat with any one of
them for 10 minutes and actually just
answered it i'd get so much clarity on
like stuff in my life yeah and it just
feels like and anytime i've done that in
the past i've always
felt like damn i'm really glad i did
this i really should do this more often
yeah
and that's where doing this sort of you
know the the therapy thing even though
there's not a specific problem yeah that
you're really trying to fix sometimes it
can be that sort of introspection and
and learning about yourself in the way
that you might with journaling um
where you just have someone to answer or
ask those questions but then also
reflect back on what they're hearing and
things like that you know a therapist
can be a mirror essentially where they
reflect back to you what they're hearing
from you and sometimes that can be quite
surprising what what you realize you're
sort of giving out you know i mean when
i mentioned this therapy thing to my mom
she was like and and i i kind of said
that oh well you know it's kind of nice
even don't have a specific problem she
was like yeah but how you know why why
can't you just talk to your friends
about that kind of stuff i was like yeah
that's a good point i probably probably
could um
but there's something about speaking to
a stranger about stuff that feels a bit
different to speaking to a friend yeah
and and sometimes um in a friendship
it's obviously a two-way thing isn't
there so you you often kind of talk for
a while and then you feel that you need
to be there for the friend and so it
goes back and forth and sometimes if you
have something you really want to sort
of deep dive on or really want to work
out
sometimes you do want that completely
private protected time where you can
just focus on that without feeling
guilty that you're
you know taking up your friend's time or
something like that so you know um
and you can get a trained perspective
whereas um friends will can be a great
great support but sometimes they might
try and solve it for us or make us feel
better in the moment and sometimes if
you're really trying to work something
out you don't need to feel better in the
moment you need to sit with it and and
keep going so that you can kind of work
through it
yeah it strikes me that therapists are
often very good at asking questions
what are like the the the the top three
techniques that a therapist would use to
kind of
go deeper in on a topic with someone um
so
they'll ask sort of very open questions
um you know the the yes or no answers
are not what you want in therapy so the
last very open questions that require
more than a yes or no answer to get
someone talking um they will just zip it
sometimes and just be completely you
know i've had whole therapy sessions
where i've barely said a word because
someone is just
going for it and they're they've got to
flow and they know exactly what they
want to work out and say and things like
that but there are other times when you
actually do a lot of talking and there
is a lot of education and so it's um
perhaps a skill of kind of being able to
take what someone is saying and and get
out on paper so you're formulating and
you are
taking a a maybe a specific time or
event a sort of he said she said or i
did this then i did that and you plot
out the process and actually
that might not be a one-off event
because it might be a pattern of
behavior that they're stuck in and then
you kind of get this bird's-eye view and
and then that person can kind of see
oh right yeah that's what i'm doing or
that's why i'm doing it and and you know
and then and there's also this kind of
it's guided discovery so you're not
advising someone do this or don't do
that
you
guide and help them to come to a point
where
they discover it for themselves and then
they work out what they want to do based
on their values or and the life they
want to create one one sort of pattern
i've noticed is that
americans who write books are much more
open with being prescriptive than brits
who write books
um every british author i've ever spoken
to feels feels a bit of a cringe about
like giving advice yeah whereas the
americans seem to be like full-on
confident about it um
i guess given that your book is
a self-help book how how did you feel
about like
giving advice
yeah it's hard isn't it as well because
like you say you know
a lot of therapy isn't about giving
advice it's about saying here's what the
research says
how might you use that and and then
helping that so you know being guided
discovery and that's why there are so
many journal prompts in there and and
activities and exercises that people can
work through
um because it's individual you know you
can give a sort of blanket piece of
advice and and it won't work for
everyone yeah um
and
it's interesting because we often talk a
lot about hey about these you know like
um sort of wellness inferences and stuff
that say you know you must get up at 5am
and you must meditate for an hour then
work out and then you know have a decent
you know special breakfast or what and
you think
yeah
but it really doesn't work for everybody
you know um there are people with
children there are people that shift
work and there are people that just have
lots of responsibilities and stuff and
so um often when you give a blanket
statement advice there are lots of
people then that that can't find it as
helpful because
it just isn't what their life looks like
you have
what i thought was a pretty hot take in
the book which is that um this whole
thing of don't care what other people
think it's not necessarily like good
advice yeah what's your what what's the
theory there yeah because we are you we
are social beings aren't we and and
um
however much you tell someone not to
care what other people think they are
built to care because and if you didn't
you wouldn't be a very social person
right you know if if i was in here and
not caring what anybody else thought of
me i could be really anti-social and and
destroy relationships that i could have
otherwise made and um
and then i'm not going to fare very well
if i'm not able to maintain
relationships and so there are opinions
that matter
some matter more than others and i think
it's all about that is working out um
whose opinions do i value yeah
and
and how can i
then manage the the discomfort if those
people whose opinions i value
disapprove of me or criticize me in some
way um and then there's a whole set of
skills around you know managing
criticism and things like that and
recognizing that it comes from some
you know another person and it's yeah
do you do you get any hate on the
internet is that something that you've
got oh i feel like i need to touch wood
now because so far
so so far so good i mean it's not been
there's you get the odd weird comment
that that feels sort of strange but um
not not huge amount um not anything that
has caused me to think i don't want to
do this yeah um and i don't really know
why maybe it's luck um maybe it's also
because it's quite a niche
um
subject that people are coming in sort
of hitting follow because they
they want that kind of information um
so yeah it's been a really lovely kind
of community actually and even people
that kind of get into the comments
support each other and and come up with
different bits of advice for each other
and help and stuff which is really
really nice um
but it does make you vulnerable doesn't
it putting content out there and i i you
know hats off to anyone who has
the courage to to make some form of
content and put it out into the world
because it's not it's not easy it makes
you feel vulnerable and anxious and
um
it doesn't feel safe to do it sometimes
you know yeah we were we ever concerned
about what your friends and family would
think when you started being a tech
talker oh hugely so i think i probably
had about
about a hundred thousand followers on
tick tock before i even told my family
or anyone that i was there and i don't
think i even told them i think my
husband told her christmas one year um
that we were doing this thing and um and
i just
i hated telling anyone i knew i hated i
didn't want to you know tell other
professionals that i knew because of the
sort of professional judgment side
but actually there's loads of therapists
and psychologists now that are all
online and doing something similar which
is great um
uh and you know my family kind of get it
a bit more now um whereas it's really
difficult thing to explain at the
beginning isn't it so i'm putting these
videos on the internet yeah what um but
now that it's a thing it's yeah a bit
easier to kind of explain how about you
did you find it difficult to kind of
share
what you were doing
with family or colleagues and stuff in
the early days yeah so when i when i
first started it was like doing doing
vlogs of my medical school elective and
so i would i would post a link in our
family whatsapp group
uh but i didn't post anything on
facebook where where i had
i
where all my friends were until like 30
30 videos in
and i was like oh hey guys you know i
did a thing i made these videos about my
elective check it out if you want as a
very kind of
and then i i did not post anything at
all on facebook from that point onwards
because i was like you know what
a i still feel a bit cringe about this
and b this is not like my friends on
facebook are not the people i'm
targeting with this content
and to this day whenever someone says
that oh i actually watch your video i
always feel like oh hello because i just
don't
the the the sort of people i'm talking
to
are not the people that are like my
friends or people older than me it's
very much people people younger than me
kind of myself when like five years ago
yeah that kind of stuff so it always
feels flattering when people actually
find stuff helpful i don't know if you
have that at all but
yeah yeah and because it's still um when
it's all online and there's this little
number of sort of views and things like
that there's a sense that it's not
really real um but when a real person
comes up to you and says
oh watched your videos and that was
really helpful there's this sort of oh
oh yes that did go out to the world
didn't it and then that sort of moment
of vulnerability of oh god people
actually saw that
i think that's a great place to end this
i'd love to end with a few kind of rapid
fiery type questions okay um
the questions will be rapid but the
answer certainly doesn't happen i'd love
for you to elaborate so if we start with
a quick fire question so um
what advice would you give to your
younger self
just keep doing everything you normally
do because um
yes i made mistakes along the way and i
did things that i would do differently
now but
they got me to where i am now so
i think there's a recognition at this
point in my life that
you can make you have to make your
mistakes along the way you have to
because you then learn from them and
they make you who you are and and
you know you i think you learn about
how strong you can be by going through
really tough times
so um
yeah i think i
it would be just just keep going it
turns out all right
uh that question who would you say has
had the biggest influence on your career
part of me wants to say
um
my parents because they i was the first
person in my family to go to university
and you know
they they didn't have huge amounts of
money so they worked really really hard
to give me that opportunity so that i
could go
um but i guess since that time since
sort of qualifying and
um
you know being a psychologist
probably my husband actually because he
sort of
you know said well why don't you try
private practice and why don't you try
and make a youtube video and why don't
you try to go on tick-tock and you know
all those things so actually um
where i probably would have kept myself
contained and done you know a single
thing he's always going go on try that
try that try and here we are
um what is one tip for someone looking
for success uh i would say it depends
what success you're looking for oh
because yeah the idea of success is
different for different people
nice and i suppose that comes back to
sort of living in alignment with your
values yeah yeah i would say yeah maybe
maybe then the tip is you know work out
what success means to you
and then start doing research on how to
live in line with that um what does the
first and last hour of your day look
like oh gosh um
so
the first hour of the day is
um is getting everybody myself and three
small children out of the house
in time for school which starts at 8 30
so um lots of rushing around grabbing
cereal bowls getting people dressed
brushing everyone's teeth and all you
know just this constant
um
go go go go go in the morning
um
so no time for those sort of idyllic you
know yoga sessions or meditation and all
that
you know everyone get on board in the
mornings and then the last hour of the
day we're usually making videos and
things like that so get to the point
where i'm kind of losing my voice or
just cannot bear to do anymore and then
um yeah kind of wrapping up on videos
and stuff the whole rushing to get the
kids out of the house
is that fun
no
no
no i mean it can be yeah it can be but
you know when you've got a deadline and
you have three small humans that
have no concept of deadlines
and no real rush to be anywhere um
you know there's a sense when you're
really young
that if something needs to happen mum
will make it happen and and so you know
teaching young children that that if you
need to get to school in time we we have
to get dressed right now so put the lego
down you know this is sort of um so it's
not always fun no i'm not going to kind
of
try and create that image that mums
should be having fun in the morning
did you consider homeschooling the kids
like
permanently
um not really
after lockdown that experience was
really really tough in terms of um
they're all different ages you know he's
got three different ages three different
sets of needs very young um you know
hats off to anyone who does permanent
home schooling what a challenge that
must be you know you have to be so on
board with
the best techniques for learning and how
to engage them because if they're not
engaged they're just not
um and actually i realized how much they
missed from school not in terms of
academics but in terms of social
experience and being with their friends
you know and
you learn so much from school
i think by just being around other kids
and learning how to relate to other
people and
and build friendships and maintain
friendships there's so much of that that
is so good about school i think what is
a
sort of physical thing that's maybe
under 100 pounds that you couldn't live
without maybe my um the light that i
used
yeah because given that half of our
videos are made at sort of 11 o'clock at
night when uh looking really ropey and
tired you know it's just
it really helps so probably that
um what book would you recommend to
anyone ah other than yours other than my
own yeah
um
i struggle with this i started like a
little book club on my instagram because
there are so i have so many books and so
many that would recommend but they're
all for different things you know
they're all for different problems or
concerns so um but actually for anyone
doing any kind of sort of creative
endeavor the the one that i
read a lot that was a recommendation
from your channel when i was writing was
i'm going to get the title wrong now but
it's the war of art isn't it oh yeah yes
they were just
brilliant nice
um
let's say um you
lose everything like all the followers
and all the money and all the clout and
fame and stuff
what would you
be doing if you didn't have all that
stuff would you try and rebuild or would
you kind of do something else what's
that i i would i would focus on being a
mom i think because that's something
that has been really difficult for me is
balancing that
and a lot of the time i've been doing
this really exciting stuff and it's been
fantastic but i have felt along the way
that it's pulling me
you know
it's been a real balance of i want to be
with the children i want to be very
present with the children and but
they're all these fantastic
opportunities that i need to
you know be my best for um so it's been
a sort of always a tight rate but
balancing that so
um i'd probably sort of pull right back
and go for the simple life
yeah i find that this is well a lot of
people say like when when you've been
doing something for a while then
you sort of then want to pull in the
other direction and
yeah get that that kind of balance back
yeah i think it's really tough when
you're sort of working and running a
family that you're constantly in a rush
so i like the idea at the moment of sort
of simplicity um but obviously you know
you always have to sort of
earn and keep a roof over your heads and
stuff so there is that um but yeah i'd
probably go for
probably back to my therapy room do a
few hours in there and then and then
make dinner for my children yeah really
simple so like
when i speak to creators we often kind
of joke about the whole like yeah well
you know i've got to
i've got to put bread on the table type
thing
usually
people are way beyond the point where
they actually have to worry about
putting bread on the table and i i've
certainly found that
the
but i need to put bread on the table it
becomes
a sort of untested assumption for just
chasing more and more and more um do you
think about that at all like i do yeah
at one point is enough enough kind of
thing yeah when is it enough and and
you certainly because it's been a
massive life change for me as well that
you know
i've always been doing all the value
stuff in the book thinking about well
you know what am mine and and am i in
line with that because a lot of the time
i've felt like it's pulling me away from
my values because i you know i
structured my career so that i could be
really present as a mom and yeah and
every time it pulls me i think oh no i
want to be here or i want to be there
but that's a great opportunity and it's
always a balancing act isn't it and i
think it's always about checking in and
seeing if if i want to pull back in this
direction you know at the moment i'm
taking a day back to um take my youngest
son to swimming lessons and things and
take into little clubs that i did with
my other children and and um so just
taking little choices and actions that
help you to kind of
come back to something that feels more
um more meaningful yes that's pretty
good um what quote or mantra do you live
by
do you know i was such a hoarder of
quote quotes when i was at university
the first time i used to have these
little notebooks where i stored little
quotes and things like that and i don't
really do it anymore but um i guess
you've got instagram and there's just
full of them isn't it um so i don't
really have a set one i guess it's like
when you've got something in your head
it's hard to like hold on yeah it's like
the the book recommendation question i
find it really hard to recommend yeah
it's like oh just tell me more about
your problems and then i'll prescribe
you a book yeah i mean i love finding a
really powerful quote at the right time
you know that really resonates at the
time but different resonate different
quotes resonate at different times so um
i don't really have one that i live by
forever and ever nice um and finally
journey or destination
journey nice everyone says that maya
asks how do you overcome the feeling of
being never enough you know there's a
whole chapter on this in the book
actually um
about sort of self-doubt and being
enough and
um
and i think i think you've done videos
haven't you before and sort of
self-sabotage and i'm not sure sorry on
imposter syndrome and
that idea of kind of getting into a
situation and not being enough
and i think
feeling that
occasionally because you're stepping
into a new environment is normal isn't
it if you're trying something new you're
out of your comfort zone it's scary
you're worried about not being enough
that would be natural and human and
allows you to kind of feel a bit
stressed and alert that allows you to
kind of step up to it yeah
if you feel it all the time
i would say sometimes that can be quite
a complex issue so um it's worth
breaking down and really kind of um
understanding where it's come from how
it plays out in your day-to-day life so
how you behave in line with that or how
you reconfirm it with some of the things
some of the choices that you make or
behaviors that you do
and then because it becomes then a whole
process of breaking some of those
patterns because you
you can't convince yourself you're
enough
by just telling yourself you're enough
your brain works on evidence which is
action you have to
you have to create evidence with action
so you start to feel enough
when you start to
behave as if you're enough
and and
by that i mean it might mean holding
boundaries better you know and and
not sort of so people-pleasing for
example or um
you know it might be looking after your
health more or whatever that thing is
you know there's probably a whole host
of things um and that's why those things
can be really helpful to work out in
therapy because it's complex and it's
long it's a life practice so if you've
spent
i don't know how old that person is but
if you spent the last 20 years of your
life not feeling enough
it's not going to change overnight yeah
it's going to take time so you know uh
so han says wha what is what are some of
the best ways to cure burnout
um
so the thing about burnout and stress
is that you know stress can be good for
us it helps us to perform helps us to
stay alert and all those things but it's
made to be short-term so um you know
that that that burnout is really your
body saying
enough already i need a rest and so they
really the only way to stop it from con
you know i think the tendency is to
experience burnout then take some huge
break and be sort of you know have a big
you know a couple of months off um go on
holiday whatever
feel better and then go back to life as
it was
and then you're gonna have the same
thing again so i think it has to be
a consistent replenishment if you're
putting stress on your body and your
mind it needs to get something back for
that it needs replenishment so you know
you you have to structure your life in a
way that gives you enough rest to
replenish otherwise then out will happen
at some point yeah i really like that
like i think a lot of people decide i'm
gonna go on a holiday for two weeks and
then i'll be cured but then they go
straight back into that pattern and yeah
yeah and there again a lot of it is that
pressure isn't it to constantly be
productive or constantly be doing
something or earning something on that
kind of thing and i mean how do you
manage it with you know this stuff could
go on forever right you could spend 24
hours a day here
how do you
replenish
i
usually like to
leave here by six or at least not have
anything in the evening so that i can
like hang out with friends and
i know that
for me what i need to do is schedule
stuff in
that i feel bad breaking a commitment to
so for example if it's a dinner with
friends like today i've got something
someone coming over to my place for
dinner at 9 00 p.m so i used to have to
be done by the vr yeah um and that's a
commitment that i have to take um i'm
also trying to figure out like can i can
i take kickboxing lessons
or join a kickboxing club that starts at
6 00 pm on a weekday to force me to
leave here at 6pm on a weekday yeah um
because i think one of the issues with
like
like all of this stuff is just so much
fun and when you're having fun it's so
easy to just like keep on doing it
because it still feels fun and doesn't
feel like work yeah but i've been
realizing recently that like
taking a step back from that and
actually thinking you know what the
videos are still going to be there
tomorrow nothing in this business is
life and death no one cares if a video
is delayed or if we don't put out a
newsletter or whatever and actually
being okay to take the foot off the gas
in terms of consistency yeah um that's
been really helpful in sort of
feeling better about this whole all of
this stuff yeah is that trusting that
it's it won't all disappear if you take
a day off or yeah trusting that it's all
good like the channel's growing even
when we don't post our videos so let's
just stop posting videos
do you take days off do you have like
weekends off or anything do you
um i don't think of them as like days
off um because there's always like stuff
going on yeah it's really nice like you
know when i came back back from pakistan
a few days ago it was a sunday afternoon
and i had nothing to do for the rest of
the day that was so nice i like cleaned
the house did the laundry
cleaned the bathroom for the first time
in a month
little stuff like that and then i
invited a friend over for a takeaway so
i want to have more of those kind of
lazy afternoons
but then i always think that and then
an opportunity will arise someone will
email me who's like some angel investor
investing in the creator oh that's kind
of cool let's hang out and then all of a
sudden the social calendar is now booked
up again so it's a it's a balancing act
it's a good problem to have yeah i guess
it's kind of the same with you when you
have so many opportunities coming your
way it's it's like you want to say yes
to a lot of things
um and it's that balance between
actually making time for yourself as
well yeah yeah and i think that's the
idea isn't it it's never putting
yourself under the pressure to do it
perfectly it's just a balance and as
long as you're aware that it's a balance
then you can just check in and see when
is it out of balance and when do i need
to kind of redirect and take some time
back and stuff nice
um
oh we've got a question from twitter
from nuno bello who says how would
someone strike a balance with welcoming
feedback um
while also and being exposed while also
trying not to be consumed by other
people's opinions um it's tricky isn't
it because you kind of we were talking
about earlier um
working out whose opinions matter most
to you i mean criticism always stings
doesn't it if somebody you know even
someone you don't know in the street
says something um disapproving or
criticizing it's gonna hurt it's not
pleasant um because we're social beings
we're made to feel that
but
um i think it can really help to get
clarity on whose opinions matter most
and and being able to
to recognize that you you can't please
everyone so if you've got your set of
values right
clear so that you know why you do what
you do
and then recognizing that some people
will like that some people won't
and that's okay
so you know
you co if you set your sort of life so
that you are trying to be approved of by
everybody all of the time
you're going to feel like a failure
pretty quick
because you're human nice oh we've got
tintin smith who asks uh what's the
psychology of research behind having a
defined purpose or calling or why i'm
torn between the simon sinek school of
thought that we all should have a why
and how we can all have one clear
definable why um and the other side of
it which is that where we're actually
not evolved to have a single defined
need uh what would love to hear your
thoughts on this yeah i think
coming from the sort of acceptance and
commitment therapy
stuff i
tend to go with you know life is layered
and complex and you have different
aspects of your life and the values in
those different aspects will be
different yeah so i i think i probably
tend to go for the lots of wise in lots
of areas
um
rather than that kind of really narrow
focus but
it's different for everybody yeah yeah
that's kind of the way that i approach
it as well if i if i think what's my
number one calling in life i'm like i
don't know what if i think kind of
roughly what i want in each of these
different domains like the wheel of life
and all the stuff and i think okay i
have more of an idea of potentially what
a good life looks like yeah connor says
what's been your favorite experience as
a result of you blowing up on tiktok
my favorite experience
this is one of them
being here of course um
favorite experience god what have we
done um
gotta try and think now
so it's it it's just bizarre actually
either from some someone who was
um sat in the therapy room every day and
seeing one person at a time to go to
sort of wild events and and wild events
but um
things like that
yeah i mean things like i mean i was
included in the female lead book um this
year
um sort of recognizing different sort of
females that are um shaping the future
apparently um and so to go to an event
like that where there were lots of
really inspiring people who are doing
incredible things was amazing and so
doing this you know it's i think it's
meeting all these incredible people who
have brilliant stories and they're doing
really interesting stuff and and having
such a reach it's really i mean it is
probably yeah meeting all the different
people and stuff yeah love it all right
julie thank you so much for coming on um
links to the book
which
is coming out soon january 6th january
the 6th and we're putting this out once
the book is out right amber cool so it's
out now the book is now out so that'll
be linked in the video description and
we'll put an image up on the screen
because we don't have a physical copy
just yet yeah and i can't wait to get it
in my hands to stick it on a little
bookshelf um it's gonna it's gonna
feature prominently in our background
next elon musk next elon musk exactly
it's gonna be great yeah thank you so
much for coming on um any any final
messages words
parting wisdom to share with the
audience just um thanks so much and and
yeah what a great great experience thank
you all right thanks all right so that's
it for this week's episode of deep dive
thank you so much for watching or
listening all the links and resources
that we mentioned in the podcast are
going to be linked down in the video
description or in the show notes
depending on where you're watching or
listening to this if you're listening to
this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the itunes
store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full hd or 4k on
youtube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching do hit the subscribe
button if you aren't already and i'll
see you next time bye